bene a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti ha
visto loro sono farisei oggi siamo sul
nuovo episodio di gta anche perché ci
sono un miliardo di cose che ancora
dobbiamo fare soprattutto con le mode
nel caso vi steste chiedendo ma come è
possibile che riesce a guidare senza ora
le mani perché sono un passeggero di
questa bella scalve a posto e mi fa
guidare a me per cortesia noi volevo
passare al posto di guida
va beh niente spero che i video vi sia
piaciuto a parte gli scherzi ragazzi sta
dato un altro paio di moduli ti
permettono di fare robe tipo getting to
neri michael e salvagente
mettiti dentro il primo veicolo come
passeggero c'è
wow che sostavano relativo visto che
minchia va bene anziché rotto pure il
vetro perché sono tuo amico capito e se
vuoi ti lascio ancora bellissima granata
davanti
cioè se riesco a ciò che poi dovrete ora
cavalca orcal h
ecco vedi a farmi giocare queste cose
sono molto meno merito anche un
pochettino dei ragazzi cosa riusciamo a
fare con queste mode nuove visto che ci
sono un sacco di 99 cosa diavolo è un
core morant è una per l'amato e vai sono
morto
che bello è un non so di che animale sia
ma va bene così la famiglia che posso
volare ma è bellissimo a salve
io ho tante domande nella mia vita ma
questa questa le batte tutte
non ho capito però va bene cambiare
ragazzi mettiamoci finalmente pietro
a parte gli scherzi alla faccia una roba
decente to back ed è questo ciao
la gente presa male per le mine che
strano pensavo fossero mille di
compagnia
questo tipo il pianeta delle scimmie
so.ge.ma posso usarla alla pistola sia
di scimmia sì perché o gli arti quindi
chi agli arti posare giustamente più in
una scimmia con la minicar
buongiorno ecco le scimmie con la
minicar mi mancavano ragazzi ceramente
sono una è bellissimo essere una scimmia
a saperlo prima valore sculetta a ciò
che cos'è un cane che c'è un po un pollo
fermi tutti possono la regalino cioè
possono spiccare dei micro voli si può
spiccare micro volo ti prego ti prego
rendimi felice ti prego a chi hai dato
del pollo stupida bimbi e bellissimo
salve vi spacco la famiglia stretta
stretta aspettato una molotov e il polo
con l'amore orca vacca il meglio e che
poi quando quando muoio ridi 21 mano
proprio è un potere il mio comunque
ragazzi allora andiamo su tempo e
mettiamo giorno perché oggi siamo qua
non per trasformarci ma per fare una
roba un po diversa allora se vediamo suo
black list
ho preparato questa cosa qua 321 del
wigan signore signore abbiamo una rampa
titanica una rampa che serve a suonare
delle macchine e provare a fare un salto
dei 100 che questo in teoria sarebbe
intento adesso speriamo la macchina
decente proviamo questa mega ramp sa
esattamente quello che volevo fare in
questo video ma innanzitutto proviamo a
fare ovviamente questa cosa con le
supercar quindi con le super macchine
quindi utilizziamo non sarà che volessi
è la più veloce quindi abbiamo subito
trofei o mio dio
questa è una macchia questa è bellissima
non pensavo che proviamo con questa
primo tentativo nel che la super rampa
ragazzi fatta con questa che è
bellissima
non ho mai visto stamattina si vede che
e dopo che non gioco ci chiami mancano
gli aggiornamenti let's go go on
non so se mai esistito uno stato così
lungo in gta occhio apposta forse poi
questo è il mio parcheggio fantastico
perfetto è esattamente quello che vorrà
quindi la macchina abbiamo parcheggiato
proviamo con un'altra macchina una un po
più power
andiamo con le sport è troviamo una
lampada ti troppo rally anzi un effetto
atene sta una di più vaga sostò cadendo
giù aiuto aiuto a iaia e niente è
cascata una macchina sopra ma fa niente
volevo solo cambiare macchina invece uno
sfogo nate 8.000 però fa nulla
tra tutte direi di provare questa qui
che tra queste mi sembrava più easy la
lampadati troppo con le lampade in
omaggio prova saltarvi stilato la sua
funzione mi sai che funziona forse cda
terro pure che peccato però cielo quasi
e fighissima sta roba fermi un attimo
che devo stare in piedi non sono venuti
pietra è rifacciamola vi prego
mamma mia questa macchia di batman
let's get my friends la prima macchina
seria tute nere me ne sto lavorando tra
l'altro proprio se ne frega
questa voglio vedere dove arriva sul
nome alla fine della strada ci arriva
teoricamente l'ex non so se è atteso in
piedi massiccia pero sono un fenomeno
ragazzi miei come entrò in strada io
nessun altro c'è anche un'altra rampa la
prendiamo
ecco questa ci ha messo rallenti
nell'altra che era gigantesca no però un
ragazzo con le rampe in gta cir sempre
sballato un sacco perché in qualsiasi
cta usavo le rampe magari vi toglie il
ralenti roma con la sua folle fallita
mazza ho fatto la roba gigantesca bravi
invece una pregasi bacca nel senso che
poco [ __ ] ok bene direi che non so
cosa sia successo ma va bene lescot
questa mousse è più veloce di quali
prima però è i neon che la rende
strafiga sarebbe bellissimo tipo
centrare un palazzo in pieno sono io la
vedo dura
cioè salire sul palazzo in via è forse
ce la faccio prego tv che ce la faccio
non ci crede no dai non è vero c'ero
riuscito mi piacevo riuscire a far sarò
bravo parcheggiata
almeno quello se volessi provarla invece
con una moto direi tipo l'ape cassi
vortex ok ami è esatto bravo quello che
pensavo 20 casco perché qua ti serve se
non mettiamo il casco in questa
situazione potremmo a morire quindi hai
fatto proprio bene a metterlo l'escaut
col drop tutto questo riuscito a volare
col drop che mi rende orgoglioso di me
stesso e molto molto bravi la mia moto è
meglio
scusami fermi tutti fermi tutti i fermi
tutti vi prego fermi tutti vi prego
let's go voglio de qua succede è
possibile mettere lecce c'è ci sono i
neon anche sul carro armato c'è anche
l'idraulica quindi per capire non
l'idraulica sul carro armato purtroppo
manca strano e un cingolato per darmi
più spinta prova a sparare indietro
non lo so se mai funziona questa roba
però ci proviamo non ha tanta
propulsione il carro armato che peccato
chi è stato incredibile bravo bravo
l'importante il pensiero ragazzi ok ecco
questa mi sembra un po difficile
salve non fate caso all'uomo sulla barca
sulla rampa
ecco bravo bravo bravo bravo da solo non
ci hanno provato tipo tipo a scivolo
allora che mi sa che non scivola peduto
che è peccato allora lo espone un'altra
macchina un treno possa spronare il
treno m 3 york demonio porco oltre
inoltre no non parte ragazzi questo è un
problema questo un problema lame ecco la
metro sulla rampa non è il massimo
però forse cadoinpiedi cosa sta succendo
mio dio
la fisica è andata un po a farsi [ __ ]
vista broker posso uscire a ero dentro e
sta pilotando il treno fantasma riuscire
poi uscire il trattore o mio dio un
trattore di servizio
fermi tutti let's go per la scienza a
quattr'occhi e velocità poi aggiungere
un trattore tra l'altro oh mio dio ma
perché l'altro rende anche un trattore
normale uno tipo cede il trattore sotto
questa ruggine è fatto con la ruggine
proprio ecco lo è se io riuscissi ad
atterrare sul tetto sarei un fenomeno
signore e signori non l'hai calvino
grazie non vedrò mai più un trattore sul
tetto in gta penso sia l'ultima volta
avrà ok fatto sottratto requa può
esplodere
non vi pare e in bici e indicibile
estrattore fan è fantastico vabbè
ragazzi devi fare un'ultima caduta ma
fatta recentemente con un magari una
macchina dell'ing facciamo a grotti
proto un prototipo 9 eccola credo che la
grotta in questo punto sia la non mi
rovinare la carrozzeria ti ammazzo tra
le top ma niente piano da mazzarri ha
deciso che è uscito dalla macchina mi
chiamo 01 ragazzi secondo me vi sia
piaciuto adesso faccio un'ultima di
scelta con con questa che come si chiama
la e l'agro è il prototipo della grotti
va bene che ha ovviamente al l'idraulico
breve spero che il vino vi sia piaciuto
spero che abbiate imparato come si
scende dalle rampe non lo fate a casa
anche se la vedo molto difficile
gesù è stato divertente
sono caduto al contrario però e non a
posto a pochi mesi è piaciuto ragazzi
con sé se mi piace soprattutto di
piacere dice sacconi contro dalla
descrizione nelle rampe di tua sorella
però vabbè io parcheggio così importante
scendere dalla macchina e nuova sinistra
che è arte questa poi schiacciate ma
questa è arte a casa mia
i ragazzi stranieri sia piaciuto
consenso che piace non mi piace anche al
comitato descrizione sono se avessi
schietto come sempre ci vediamo prossimo
video belle ragazze
[Musica]